Winter is almost here.
The day gets shorter and the night gets longer.
Right.
And the weather is getting colder.
It is time to go back home.
Hurry up.
What time is it now?
It's six thirty.
It gets dark.
The snowflakes get bigger.
Let's go out and make a snowman.
That's a good idea!
Dark clouds begin to gather, they get darker and darker.
A storm is coming, coming, coming.
Strong winds begin to blow and the sky gets darker.
Clouds move over the house and lightning flashes all around.
Thunder crashes loudly, and the rain begins to fall, fall, fall.
The rain falls, falls, falls and the winds blow, blow, blow.
Then, the rain stops falling and the winds stop blowing.
The sun comes out and Tim and Pam come out, too.